ya aprendimos que un campo magnético
ejerce una fuerza sobre una carga en
movimiento pero también ya vimos que una
corriente induce un campo magnético
entonces una pregunta más o menos
natural es cuál es el efecto que tiene
un cierto alambre por el cual fluye una
corriente en otro alambre en el cual
también fluye una corriente déjame hacer
un dibujo para explicarte más o menos a
qué me refiero
entonces imaginemos que por acá tenemos
un alambre con este color y por acá
tenemos otro alambre con este color va
entonces son dos alambres y vamos a
poner corrientes van entonces en este en
el de la izquierda voy a poner una
corriente hacia arriba que le voy a
llamar y uno
y 1 y acá en el de la derecha también
voy a poner una corriente hacia arriba
podría ir hacia el otro lado pero
ahorita vamos a hacer este caso una
corriente hacia arriba que le voy a
llamar y 2 va además de esta información
también es importante saber a qué
distancia están estos dos alambres como
ya platicamos en el vídeo pasado
entonces a esta distancia le voy a
llamar r de radio y bueno le pongo radio
por lo que platicamos antes de que de
que el campo magnético que genera este
alambre o este alambre tiene que ver con
círculos concéntricos o bien con un
cilindro o con varios cilindros que
tienen a este alambre como eje bueno
vamos a reflexionar tantito en qué
sucedería así sin ponerle nada de
números nada más viendo cómo actúan las
fuerzas y así va vamos a ver cuál sería
el efecto del campo magnético que genera
este primer alambre en el alambre número
2 vamos a ponerle números este de aquí
es el alambre número 1 y este de acá es
el alambre número 2
muy bien entonces queremos ver qué
efecto tiene el alambre uno en el
alambre dos lo primerito es ver pues que
hace el alambre uno y el alambre uno
como platicamos en el vídeo anterior
genera un campo magnético que se ve más
o menos así verdad que va haciendo
círculos concéntricos que damos que de
este lado del lado izquierdo
teníamos que que salía que el campo
magnético salía
y del lado derecho del campo magnético
entra entonces por acá entra entra y de
hecho incluso por acá entra aunque esté
a una distancia muy grande simplemente
aquí va a ser muy débil va pero mira lo
estoy poniendo por con color rosa para
que sepamos que tiene que ver con este
como le hacíamos para determinar eso
pues hacíamos la regla de agarre con la
mano derecha que era poner el pulgar en
dirección de la corriente y los dedos
los dedos de la mano derecha
naturalmente nos decían hacia donde
hacia dónde giraba este estos círculos
concéntricos vale entonces teníamos algo
más o menos de este estilo a esta
nuestra mano agarrando el alambre y
entonces gira hacia allá de este lado
entra de este lado sale muy bien
entonces ahora qué pasa bueno pues este
y uno está generando un campo magnético
que de este lado está afectando ahí dos
y lo está afectando con dirección hacia
adentro de la pantalla va hacia adentro
de la pantalla bueno entonces con esto
ya tenemos información suficiente para
ver cuál es el efecto sobre y dos por
qué pues porque ya teníamos una
formulita déjame ponerla en color azul
así para saber qué tiene que ver con dos
teníamos que la fuerza que ejercía un
campo magnético sobre una cierta porción
de un alambre era igual era igual a la
corriente que fluían la corriente
multiplicada por el producto cruz de la
longitud le voy a poner el 2 todavía no
le marcado la voy a poner por acá
entonces digamos que nos importa este
cachito del alambre vamos a ponerle que
este es l 2 y que va en dirección de la
corriente por convención va entonces es
igual a la corriente pobre el producto
cruz de la longitud 2 con el campo
magnético ahora este campo magnético lo
voy a poner con color rosa y le voy a
llamar b 1 para acordarnos que es justo
este que ya dibujamos va el que entra de
este lado y está generado por el alambre
1 muy bien entonces ahí tenemos la
formulita y aquí ya podemos calcular
todo si tuviéramos números pero bueno
antes de meterle numeritos en qué
dirección iría vamos a ver qué pasa pues
este y 2 es un escalar entonces no
afecta la dirección todo está dado por
este producto cruz y para calcular la
dirección de un producto cruz hay que
utilizar la regla de la mano derecha
ahora sí la normal y está entonces
déjame pintar por acá este mi mano
derecha para ver cómo quedaría l 12 es
el dedo índice que va hacia arriba
entonces me quedaría algo así
entonces ese de ahí es el dedo índice
que va en dirección de l 2 el 2 luego el
dedo medio lo tenemos que poner en
dirección del campo que observa está
hacia adentro entonces el dedo medio
digamos que sea y es mi dedo medio que
está apuntando hacia adentro por ahí
están los otros dedos más o menos va y
que sucede con el pulgar si está en la
mano derecha pues apunta hacia acá
verdad hacia la izquierda entonces ahí
tenemos la mano y por lo tanto la fuerza
va hacia acá la fuerza va hacia acá
ahora para no confundirnos de cuál
fuerza es cual a esta fuerza déjame
llamarle la fuerza que el alambre uno
ejerce sobre el alambre 2 bueno debido
al campo magnético entonces el uno
ejerce sobre el 2 esa va a ser mi
notación el 1 al 2 ok entonces qué
sucede la fuerza va hacia el alambre 1
entonces digamos si este alambre
estuviera fijo la corriente de aquí lo
que está haciendo es atraer a este
alambre de acá bueno eso está padre
verdad qué crees que suceda ahora con la
otra
con efe 21 efe 21
bueno pues va a pasar algo muy similar
verdad vamos a ver qué pasa y poquito a
poquito mira aquí tenemos ahí dos que es
esta corriente y tenemos el alambre otra
vez la corriente va hacia arriba
entonces lo primero que vamos a hacer es
ver cómo está el campo magnético pero
como la corriente otra vez va hacia
arriba
este mismo dibujo sirve entonces otra
vez el campo de este lado entra de este
lado sale sale sale sale incluso por acá
sale con poquita fuerza pero bueno sale
entonces va hacia afuera de la pantalla
y ahora como nos quedaría nuestra
fórmula pues ahora lo que nos quedaría
es que f f de 21 es igual ahora el
alambre en el cual se está ejerciendo la
fuerza es el 1 entonces la corriente que
nos interesa es 1 multiplicada por una
longitud y una longitud l 1 vamos a
ponerle aquí el e1
producto cruz con el campo magnético
pero ahora el que ejerce este de acá
entonces vamos a ponerle por b 2 vale
flechita cerramos paréntesis y sería
bueno marcar la longitud entonces la voy
a marcar acá digamos que es esta
longitud la que nos interesaba estar acá
es l una muy bien otra vez ahí ya
tenemos nuestra fórmula hacia donde
quedaría la dirección de la de la fuerza
pues vamos a hacer otra regla de la mano
derecha esa la voy a hacer de este lado
y ahora como nos quedaría pues una vez
más el dedo índice apunta hacia arriba
en dirección de l 1 l 1 va hacia arriba
ahora nos quedaría algo así ahora hacia
dónde está apuntando v2 pues sobre el
campo va hacia fuera de la pantalla
entonces me quedaría así verdad este
sería mi dedo índice apuntando hacia
afuera y de este lado tendría mis otros
dedos
ahí está el y el anular y por acá está
el meñique y por acá viene la mano más o
menos algo así y de esta forma el pulgar
apunta hacia la derecha
muy bien entonces qué sucede que ahora
tenemos la fuerza 2 1
hacia la derecha eso está muy bien
verdad todo todo coincide todo cuadra
muy bien entonces es el 2 se acerca el 1
y el 1 se acerca 2 vayan los alambres se
atraen mutuamente bueno si estos
alambres estuvieran en el espacio
entonces se estarían acercando poco a
poco pero luego empezarían a acercarse
más rápido y cada vez más rápido pero no
sólo eso sino que además se acercarían y
de modo que su aceleración cada vez es
más y más grande pues en fin en el
siguiente vídeo vamos a ver estas mismas
ideas pero ahora sí vamos a meterle
numeritos nos vemos hasta la próxima